hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer on the
Android team at Google I work on
graphics and animation and today I
wanted to talk about drawable animations
specifically I want to talk about the
transition drawable this is a way to
provide a capability for you to
crossfade between representations of
graphics in your views so let's take a
quick look at the demo which I call
cross-fading it's a fascinating demo
that's going to crossfade between two
colored rectangles exactly the kind of
activity that you probably want to write
and sell on the Play Store so here we
have a red rectangle and when I click on
it we're going to see a green rectangle
and when we click on the green one we're
going to see the red one and back and
forth and if we click in the middle
it'll stop the animation and go in
Reverse
okay so not terribly interesting the
code is slightly more interesting let's
take a look at that now so we have this
class called crossfading it's an
activity it keeps track of the current
drawable so there knows which one to
transition to and we can go in here and
see how we do that first we get the
image view then we create a couple of
bitmaps we're going to create a red
bitmap and a green bitmap and put them
in the image view but instead of just
installing it as the drawable in the
image view we're actually going to
create this different kind of draw we'll
call it a transition drawable and this
one takes an array of objects these
drawables that we've created these
bitmap drawables that now hold the red
and the green bitmaps so we create the
transition drawable with those and you
can think of this as being layers in
that drawable so it's a transition
drawable that's actually a set of
drawables consisting of two and the red
one is the first one that we created so
that's going to be in back and the green
one is in front but the green one is not
visible by default right so it's kind of
an invisible layer sitting on top of the
first one that you loaded there and then
when we click we're going to fade
between these so we go down here and we
listen for clicks on the image view if
the current draw Bowl is zero which
means we're now looking at the red one
that first one loaded then we must need
to start the transition so that we can
see the green went on top so we say
start transition and we give it a
duration so this time it's going to run
for
500 milliseconds and then it'll fade in
the green one over the red so it's not
really doing a crossfade instead you see
the red one and then we basically fade
in the green one on top of it and then
we set the current draw Bowl so that we
can track that so that we know next time
we click which which one are we going to
transition to if you want to go in
Reverse you don't start the transition
because start transition always fades in
the one that's on top so if we did that
every time you would always see the fade
into green which is probably not the
kind of crossfade effect that you're
looking for instead if we want to go in
Reverse we need to fade out the one on
top and to do that you call reverse
transition so reverse transition will
basically fade out the one that's on top
and then you see the one the the first
one that was loaded the one that's on
the bottom so we start transition we
fade in the green reverse transition we
fade out to red if we do it in the
middle that's fine
if we're in the middle of start
transition we're halfway there and then
we click on it then we know that we need
to go back to red and we call reverse
transition it just stops and reverses on
the fly this is kind of a useful
effective you want to do something
really simple to crossfade between
representations of two drawables it's
not really good for a general
cross-fading system if you have a
picture viewer let's say where you're
going between several different images
there'd be a little bit more tracking to
say okay well now these are my two
drawables now these are my two drawables
there's probably a better way of doing
this which we'll see in a future episode
using a more robust animation system but
for doing really simple crossfades
between two bitmap drawable
representations this is a pretty easy
class to use and that's it for today
thanks